hey how's it going I'm Carlos good to
meet you nice to meet you can you
describe for me the feeling of
presenting this to this Comic-Con crowd
I'm still feeling it it's kind of like
you're weak in the knees you just feel
kind of overwhelmed but luckily we had
um Stephen Colbert as the moderator so
he kept us on track and he's such a a
fan and talking buff that having his
Blessing really kind of calmed everybody
down I feel like Steven's sort of been
single-handedly keeping the Lord of the
Rings Legend alive then we should tell
him that that would mean a lot yeah
what's it been like having all of like
there's 23 of you here and you all get
to share this experience together well
because of the way we made the show
especially during covet we were
sequestered in New Zealand so we became
very close very quickly out of necessity
um part of the fun for me is watching it
and seeing the brilliant work of the
people that I really care about so
that's uh that's rare and um probably my
favorite aspect of it the characters
that people that are fans of the movies
know are descended from the characters
in this series right right
was there a pressure or responsibility
that you felt as an actor to bring like
those stories to life and tell them uh
in a way that's true to the fans of the
lore well what's great about Peter
Jackson's work and what we're doing is
that we're all returning to the source
material we're all inspired by tolkien's
writing so I feel like if you have your
eye on that Vision then you're in a safe
place
um so I don't mind the pressure because
also
um the pressure of it being good is the
job I want it to be good you know the
pressure is what motivates you and makes
you do that extra bit of research
pressure creates diamonds my friends
yeah exactly wow yes exactly can I use
that in the next interview because
that's 100
tell them I said it yeah exactly
original cast of
a Trilogy would you love to know would
become a fan of your show ooh Ian
McKellen I'd like to think that he's got
a bowl of popcorn and he kicks his feet
up and he goes that's pretty good too
how awesome would it be to run into him
one day and be like and he just gives
you his Blessing oh that'd be very nice
he's a brilliant actor in in everything
that he does that would mean a lot uh
now we know this is like the biggest
budget television series ever you can
see it on the screen but was that
reflected in the craft table as well
[Laughter]
they did Keep Us fed which was nice but
that I mean there is a lot of talk about
the amount of money but it was also the
jobs I mean the the Wardrobe Department
was an Army of the best crafts people on
the planet and that's the money they
used to pay their mortgage and send
their kids to school like it was um
it's what this show requires how often
were you in costume on set just finding
yourself going wow wow wow very cool and
you get comfortable with it and you kind
of it becomes second nature but every
once in a while there's a a crew member
that's going your highness did you walk
past and you're like all right right oh
yeah I'm still king that's awesome man
hey congratulations we're looking
forward to show so much